翻訳: 嶋田 朋恵
校正: Hiroko Kawano
皆さん 初めまして
私は 彫刻家で 現代アーティストの
鈴木一太郎といいます
このような作品を作っています
この手に持っている作品のような
「ピクセルアート」と呼ばれる手法を
使った作品作りをしています
皆さんは こんな経験はないでしょうか？
例えば 憧れの人物に
実際に会った時に
テレビや写真で見たイメージと
ちょっと違うな というような経験です
この話を 彫刻の話に
近づけてみましょう
皆さんは かの有名な
このダビデ像をご存知ですか？
では皆さんは このダビデ像の
サイズをご存知でしょうか？
フィレンツェの
アカデミア美術館に置かれている
このミケランジェロが作ったダビデ像は
高さ なんと５メートル以上もある
大きな彫刻なのです
また皆さんは ダビデ像の後ろ姿を
想像することができるでしょうか？
皆さんの頭の中にある
ダビデ像のイメージというのは
この写真のような真正面の
イメージしかないのではないでしょうか？
私は 現代っ子なのですが
インターネットや テレビゲームや
コンピュータが大好きです
彫刻家であるにも関わらず
恥ずかしながら
私がこの目で実際に 世界の有名な彫刻作品を
見たことがあるのは指で数えるほどで
そのほとんどを インターネットや教科書の
画像でしか見たことがありません
そんな私が なぜ 彫刻というものに興味を持ち
そして 現代アーティストとして
この様な表現をしているのか
今日はお話したいと思います
私が育った町は
とても自然が豊かなところです
そして 家の周りには山と畑しか
ないような とても小さな町でした
そんな小さな町の中でも
私の家は ちょっとだけ
変な家として有名でした
母屋が新築の木造建築で
庭には バンガローが建てられていました
このバンガローは 父の趣味なのですが
私と父の２人で建築したものなのです
小学校低学年の頃に
このバンガローを作ったのですが
本当は私は 友達と遊びたかったのですが
厳しい父だったので
私の幼少期の貴重な時間は
このバンガローの建築に費やされていきました
今でも 少しだけ
父のことを恨んでいます
（笑）
ほどなくして 1996年
私が８歳の頃です
世の中では ポケットモンスターという
ゲームが大流行していました
家の教育方針で TVゲームを
買ってもらっていなかった私は
幼少期の遊びの時代を
潰されたという恨みの思いと
そして 学校の中で 私だけがポケモンを
持っていないという疎外感から
そのときに 父に必死に頼み込んでようやく
ポケモンをゲットすることができたのです
それから 私のゲーム熱が
大爆発します
私は お小遣いを貯めて
色々なゲームを買いあさりました
その頃は ちょうど家庭にパソコンが
普及し始めた頃でもあり
私はコンピュータやインターネットなどに
強い興味を持ったことを覚えています
そうした中でも 周りの豊かな自然と
そして父の日曜大工を —
日曜大工というレベルではないですが —
を手伝いながら
コンピュータも大好きで
アナログとデジタルの両方の感覚を
自分の中に取り入れながら成長していきました
そして高校生になった私は
美術科のある高校に進学しました
結局 父の影響が絶大で
日常から物作りに親しんでいた私は
彫刻を勉強したいと思うようになりました
また 私は美術の成績が
優秀だったので
自分は 美術の才能があるんだと
思い込んでいました
しかしそれは 大きな勘違いでした
美術科には 本当に才能の
ある人がたくさんいました
私はその人たちの作品を見たときに
自分が ただ真面目に授業を受けていたから
美術の成績が良かったんだということに
気付かされてしまいました
そして美術大学の受験では
私は不合格となり
浪人生活を送るようになります
その浪人生活の中で
私は必死に受験対策のための
デッサンや彫刻の技術を学びました
そうすることでようやく翌年 私は
芸術大学に合格することができたのです
その頃は 「実は私は美術が
下手だったんだ」という思いと
「浪人をしてしまった」という
コンプレックスから
受験の感覚から抜け出すことが
できませんでした
大学に入ってからも 学部の４年間は
自分らしい オリジナリティのある作品作りが
できなかったことを 今でも思い出します
そして その後 私は大学院に進学します
大学院に入学したての頃 私は
ある一つのテーマにたどり着きます
それは 「亡霊」 です
私が道を歩いていると
交差点のところに いつも花束が
置かれているところがありました
それは おそらくそこで
あったであろう交通事故に
遭われた方のために
置かれた花束だったと思います
私はその交通事故のことを
知っている訳ではありません
しかし ただ花が置いてあるだけなのに
その空間に強烈な存在感を感じたのです
私は この 「実在の物が無くても
存在感を表せる」 という感覚を
自分の彫刻作品に取り込んで 作品を
作ってみたいと思うようになりました
この「亡霊」というテーマを元に
作った作品が この作品です
これは透明樹脂と呼ばれる
文字通り透明なプラスチックによって
服の形を模った作品です
私は「モノの亡霊」と称して
シリーズの作品を作りました
日常の中で 忘れ去られていくモノや
過去のモノ
そして 頭の中だけにあるイメージを
透明樹脂によって
形作ろうと思ったのです
これらの作品は大学の中で
一定の評価を受けたのですが
私は まだ自分のオリジナリティを
獲得できていないと思いました
あるとき教授に 「確かにこれは透明
だけども実際に物は存在しているから
君の言っているような 『実在の物が無く
ても存在感を表現できる』というところまでは
到達することができないのではないか？」
という指摘を受けたときに
私も思わず「確かにそうだな」
と思い込んでしまいました
そうやって試行錯誤しながら
私は自分の作品を考えていたのですが
実はその時 祖母の介護をしながら
大学院に通っていました
作品作りに思い悩んでいた私は
祖母の介護施設におもむくことで
彼女と 話をしたり
身の回りの世話をすることで
心の平穏を得ていました
そうはいっても やはり介護は大変で
生活と介護の中で 忙しくなり
私が自分の作品について考えられる時間が
どんどん減っていってしまいました
仕方がないので 私はもっと
生活の中から 作品作りの
ヒントを得ようと思い
あまり難しいことを考えずに
自分が楽しい作品を作ろうということで
自分の 趣味であるゲームから
作品のアイディアを考えようと
思うようになったのです
そして 私にとってゲームといえば
そう ポケモン です
ポケモンが発売した当時には
まだまだ多く使われていた
ピクセルアートの手法を使って
自分の作品を作ってみようと
思うようになりました
その時に作った作品が
このような作品です
この作品を作ってみると
一つ面白い発見がありました
作品を写真に撮ってみると
ゲームの中のキャラクターが
まるで現実に現れたように
感じられたのです
私は このことから
彫刻を作るのだけれども
その作品を写真に撮るという前提で
作ってみるのも面白いのではないかと
思うようになりました
そしてこの作品を どんどん
深めていこうと思ったのです
そしてこの作品に
より彫刻的な問題を付け加えて
古代彫刻をテーマにして
作品を作ろうと思いました
これが その作品です
この作品の制作案を
とあるコンクールに応募しました
そうすると なんと審査に通り
私は補助を受けながら
作品を作れるようになったのです
初めて 仕事として作品が
作れるようになった私はとても喜び
それを祖母は 一緒に喜んでくれました
そして最終的にはこの作品はそのコンクールで
グランプリを受賞することができたのですが
残念ながら その発表の合間に
祖母は亡くなってしまったため
その報告をすることは叶いませんでした
私は身近に 「祖母が亡くなる」
という経験をして
もう一度 「亡霊」や
「存在するようで存在しない」というものを
もう一度 深く考えてみる必要がありました
そして 「存在とは何なのか」 ということを
もう一度 強く考えることを迫られたのです
[存在]
私は祖母が亡くなって
不思議と 喪失感を感じることが
ありませんでした
なぜなら 私は 祖母の存在を
まだ身近に感じていたからです
祖母が亡くなってから
私は彼女が住んでいた家から
大学院に通うようになりました
そうした中で 彼女が生前使っていた物を
見たり触れたりすることで
彼女の存在を感じていました
また 彼女がそこに居た姿や
共に交わした会話を思い出すことで
存在を身近に感じていたのです
私は祖母が大好きだったので
彼女の写真や動画を
たくさん撮っていました
そうすることで 居なくなったとしても
私は 祖母の存在を身近に感じることができ
一緒に過ごした日々を
ありありと思い出すことができました
だから 私は喪失感を感じなかったのです
私は この感覚の中にこそ
自分が本当に表現したいテーマが
隠されているのではないかと思い
自分の頭の中をもう一度
紐解いてみようと思いました
ここからは 私の考える
「存在」というものについて
お話しをしたいと思います
皆さんは 存在とは何だと思いますか？
触れられるものでしょうか？
それとも 触れられないものでしょうか？
確かに 触られるものも存在です
しかし それだけが存在なのでしょうか？
このレオ君は 私の友人が飼っている
柴犬をモチーフにしたものです
しかし 実は 私は レオ君に
一度も会ったことがないのです
大好きだけれども
動物アレルギーなので
実際に会うことはできません
しかし 私は友人に頼み込んで
レオ君の写真や動画を
たくさん送ってもらいました
そうすることで どんどん私の頭の中に
レオ君の姿や形が形成されていくのです
あくまで想像なのですが
私は 頭の中でレオ君を一瞬にして
作り上げることができます
テレビゲームの中での感覚も
私は同じような錯覚を覚えます
確かに テレビゲームの中での出来事は
実際の出来事ではありません
その中に登場するキャラクターも
実在の存在ではありません
しかしポケモンをプレイしていた
当時の私は 本当に旅をして
そして 仲間と共に苦労し
様々な困難に立ち向かい
最終的にはボスを倒して
「ポケモンマスターになったのだ！」
という達成感があるのです
その実感は 私の中で
実際の体験に勝るとも劣らない
強烈な実感として存在しているのです
このような感覚は あくまで
私の個人的な感覚なのですが
現代を生きる インターネットや
コンピュータやテレビゲームに親しんでいる
皆さんの中にも 共感する部分が
あるのではないでしょうか？
そのような現代を生きる我々にとって
実際に このように
面と向かって行うやりとりと
インターネット上のやり取りのような
実際には会っていない やりとりを
区別するという考えはあるでしょうか？
昔から 実際に会わないで やりとりをする
手紙というものがありましたが
現代においては 技術の進歩によって
よりスピード感が増し リアリティが増していて
現実のやり取りと ほぼ区別が
つかないような状況になっています
そして テレビゲームや映像表現などは
昔に比べて格段に
リアリティを増してきています
昨年は VR ＝ヴァーチャル
リアリティ 元年などとも言われ
実際には 目の前に無いのだけれども
ゲームの世界や 空想の世界が
実際に目の前に立ち現れたかのように
感じさせる装置も登場しました
現代においては 存在しないものが
現実の存在にどんどん近づいてきています
このようなことに対してマイナスの
側面を考える人も多くいるでしょうが
私は 実際には会うことができない人や
失われたもの そして
行くことができない場所への
思いなどを実現することによって
人々の心を癒したり
人々に希望を与えるような
プラスの側面も多くあるのでは
ないかと考えています
最後に 私は
現代アーティストを名乗っています
皆さんの中でも
現代アートとは 難しい —
そして 抽象的でよく分からないというような
考えを持っている人がいると思います
では皆さんは 現代アートとは
何を目的として作られているか
ご存知でしょうか？
現代アートとは
現代を生きる人々や社会の思想
そして物事の捉え方
哲学 というようなものを
目に見える形の作品として
表現しているのが 現代アートなのです
そして現代の社会において
何が善悪なのか？
そして 何が美しくて何が醜いのか？
というものを
目に見える形に 落とし込んでいるのが
我々 現代アーティストの役割なのです
現代の社会によって
私の作品は大きく様変わりしました
彫刻というのは 古代から続く表現の
文脈の上に成り立っているのですが
現代の状況によって
変わらざるを得なくなってきているのです
現代を生きる皆さん達にとって
日々の中で感じる新しい感覚や
自分の思いついた新しいアイデアというものを
自分なりに表現してみることで
それはアートになると思います
今日は 私の話を聞いてくれて
ありがとうございました
（拍手）